she's gonna love you hope so of course
she doesn't really got a choice hey hey
are you boy it's good to finally meet
you I'm gonna meet you too Tom Sarah
Sarah Taha you guys want something from
the bar yes you got two sodas yeah it's
so good good fun I meet your boyfriend
oh but no he's not my boyfriend but
didn't you bring him to your sister's
wedding yeah I mean we're friends and we
hook up and we're going dates we're not
dating you know there's no pressure um
sure yeah dad
I want you to meet my really really
special friend Rachel so nice to meet
you nice to meet you it's not official
no will you move in with me oh gosh
can't wait to have a roommate that I
bang maybe it is your fault for a change
oh wow oh it's my fault are you kidding
me can you need a girlfriend please get
it down hey she's not my girlfriend
she's my best friend who I want to spend
the rest of my life with
it's meant so much to me that we've been
able to keep it so chill past four years
I can't wait to live this long life of
low commitment hanging out only when my
work isn't too crazy okay well I now
pronounce you husband away Oh
raising her as friends we live together
and are married and share everything in
our lives with each other
[Music]
no no starts and I am so sorry very loss
it's fine
we weren't even that serious
[Music]
[Music]